The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Today
we're going to keep
on going with related rates.
And you may recall
that last time we
were in the middle of a
problem with this geometry.
There was a right triangle.
There was a road.
Which was going this
way, from right to left.
And the police were up here,
monitoring the situation.
30 feet from the road.
And you're here.
And you're heading this way.
Maybe it's a two lane
highway, but anyway it's
only going this direction.
And this distance was 50 feet.
So, because you're moving,
this distance is varying
and so we gave it a letter.
And, similarly, your distance
to the foot of the perpendicular
with the road is also varying.
At this instant it's
40, because this is a 3,
4, 5 right triangle.
So this was the situation
that we were in last time.
And we're going to pick
up where we left off.
The question is,
are you speeding
if the rate of change
of D with respect to t
is 80 feet per second.
Now, technically
that would be -80,
because you're going
towards the policemen.
Alright, so D is shrinking at
a rate of -80 feet per second.
And I remind you that
95 feet per second
is approximately
the speed limit.
Which is 65 miles per hour.
So, again, this is
where we were last time.
And, got a little
question mark there.
And so let's solve this problem.
So, this is the setup.
There's a right triangle.
So there's a relationship
between these lengths.
And the relationship is
that x^2 + 30^2 = D^2.
So that's the first
relationship that we have.
And the second
relationship that we have,
we've already written down.
Which is dx/dt - oops, sorry.
dD/dt = -80.
Now, the idea here is
relatively straightforward.
We just want to use
differentiation.
Now, you could solve for x.
Alright, x is the square
root of D^2 - 30^2.
That's one possibility.
But this is basically
a waste of time.
It's a waste of your time.
So it's easier, or
easiest, to follow
this method of implicit
differentiation,
which I want to encourage
you to get used to.
Namely, we just
differentiate this equation
with respect to time.
Now, when you do that, you have
to remember that you are not
allowed to plug in a constant.
Namely 40, for t.
You have to keep in
mind what's really
going on in this problem
which is that x is moving,
it's changing.
And D is also changing.
So you have to
differentiate first
before you plug in the values.
So the easiest thing is
to use, in this case,
implicit differentiation.
And if I do that, I get 2x
dx/dt is equal to 2D dD/dt.
No more DDT left.
We hope.
Except in this blackboard.
So there's our situation.
Now, if I just plug in,
now I can plug in values.
So this is after
taking the derivative.
And, indeed, we
have here 2 times
the value for x which
is 40 at this instant.
And then we have dx/dt.
And that's equal to 2
times D, which is 50.
And then dD/dt is -80.
So the 80's cancel and we
see that dx/dt = -100 feet
per second.
And so the answer to
the question is yes.
Although you
probably wouldn't be
pulled over for this
much of a violation.
So that's-- right, it's
more than 65 miles an hour,
by a little bit.
So that's the end
of this question.
And usually in these rate
of change or related rates
questions, this is considered to
be the answer to the question,
if you like.
So that's one example.
I'm going to give
one more example
before we go on to
some other applications
of implicit differentiation.
So my second example is going
to be, you have a conical tank.
With top of radius
4 feet, let's say.
And depth 10 feet.
So that's our situation.
And then it's being
filled with water.
So, is being filled with water.
At 2 cubic feet per minute.
So there is our situation.
And then the question is,
how fast is the water rising
when it is at depth 5 feet?
So if this thing is
half-full in the sense--
well not half-full in
terms of total volume,
but half-full in
terms of height.
What's the speed at which
the water is rising.
So, how do we set up
problems like this?
Well, we talked
about this last time.
The first step is to set
up a diagram and variables.
And I'm just going
to draw the picture.
And I'm actually going to
draw the picture twice.
So here's the conical tank.
And we have this
radius, which is 4.
height, which is 10.
So that's just to allow me
to think about this problem.
Now, it turns out because
we have a varying depth
and so on, and this
is just the top.
That I'd better depict also
the level at which the water
actually is at present.
And furthermore, it's better
to do this schematically,
as you'll see.
So the key point here is
to draw this triangle here.
Which shows me the 10 and
shows me the 4, over here.
And then imagine that
I'm filling it partway.
So maybe we'll put that water
level in in another color here.
So here's the water level.
And the water level,
I'm going to depict
that horizontal
distance here, as r.
That's going to be my variable.
That's the radius of
the top of the water.
So I'm taking a
cross-section of this,
because that geometrically
the only thing I
have to keep track of.
At least initially.
So this is our water level.
And it's really rotated around.
But I'm depicting just this
one half-slice of the picture.
And then similarly,
I have the height.
Which is this dimension there.
Or, if you like, the
depth of the water.
So the water has filled us
up, up to this point here.
So I set it up this
way so that it's clear
that we have two triangles
here, and that one
piece of information we
can get from the geometry
is the similar
triangles information.
Namely, that r / h = 4 / 10.
So this is by far the most
typical geometric fact
that you'll have to
glean from a picture.
So that's one piece
of information
that we get from this picture.
Now, the second
thing we have to do
is set up formulas for
the volume of water,
and then figure out
what's going on here.
So the volume of
water is-- of a cone.
So again, you have to know
something about geometry
to do many of these problems.
So you have to know that
the volume of a cone
is 1/3 base times height.
Now, this one is upside down.
The base is on the top
and it's going down
but it works the same way.
That doesn't affect volume.
So it's 1/3, and the base
is pi r^2, that's the base,
and times h, which
is the height.
So this is the setup
for this problem.
And now, having
our relationship,
we have one relationship left
that we have to remember.
Because we have one more piece
of information in this problem.
Namely, how fast the
volume is changing.
It's going at 2 cubic
feet per minute.
It's increasing, so that
means that dV/dt = 2.
So I've now gotten
rid of all the words
and I have only formulas left.
I started here with the
words, I drew some pictures,
and I derived some formulas.
Actually, there's
one thing missing.
What's missing?
Yeah.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
What you want to find.
What I left out is the question.
So the question is, what
is dh(dt when h = 5?
So that's the question here.
Now, we've got the whole
problem and we never
have to look at it
again if you like.
We just have to pay
attention to this piece here.
So let's carry it out.
So what happens here.
So look, you could do this
by implicit differentiation.
But it's so easy to express
r as a function of h
that that seems kind of foolish.
So let's write r as 2/5 h.
That's coming from this
first equation here.
And then let's
substitute that in.
That means that V =
1/3 pi (2/5 h)^2 h.
And now I have to
differentiate that.
So now I will use
implicit differentiation.
It's very foolish at this
point to take cube roots
to solve for h.
You just get yourself
into a bunch of junk.
So there is a stage at
which we're still using
implicit differentiation here.
I'm not going to try to solve
for h as a function of V.
Instead I'm just
differentiating straight
out from this formula,
which is relatively
easy to differentiate.
So this is dV/dt,
which of course is 2,
is equal to, and if I
differentiate it I just get
this constant, pi/3, this
other constant, (2/5)^2.
And then I have to
differentiate h^3.
(h^2)h.
So that's 3h^2 dh/dt.
That's the chain rule.
So now let's plug in
all of our numbers.
Again, the other
theme is, you don't
plug in numbers, fixed
numbers, until everything
has stopped moving.
At this point, we've already
calculated our rates of change.
So now I can put in the numbers.
So, 2 is equal to pi/3 (2/5)^2
times 3, and then h was 5,
so this is 5^2.
And then I have dh/dt.
There's only one unknown thing
left in this problem, which
is dh/dt.
Everything else is a number.
And if you do all
the cancellations,
you see that this cancels this.
One of the 2's cancels -
well, this cancels this.
And then one of the
2's cancels that.
So all told what we have
here is that dh/dt = 1/2 pi.
And so that happens
to be feet per second.
This is the whole story.
Questions, way back there.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Where did I get--
the question is where did I
get r = 2/5 h from.
The answer was, it came
from similar triangles,
which is over here.
I did this similar
triangle thing.
And I got this
relationship here.
r/h = 4/10, but then
I canceled it, got 2/5
and brought the h over.
Another question, over here.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: The question
was the following.
Suppose you're at this stage,
can you write from here dV/dh
- so, suppose you're here -
and work out what this is.
It's going to end up being
some constant times h^2.
And then also use
dV/dt = dV/dh dh/dt.
Which the chain rule.
And the answer is yes.
We can do that, and indeed that
is what my next sentence is.
That's exactly what I'm saying.
So when I said this-- sorry,
when you said this, I did that.
That's exactly what I did.
This chunk is exactly dV/dh.
That's just what I'm doing.
OK.
So, definitely, that's
what I had in mind.
Yeah, another question.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: You're asking
me whether my arithmetic is
right or not?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Pi - per second.
Oh.
This should - no, OK, right.
I guess it's per minute.
Since the other
one is per minute.
Thank you.
Yes.
Was there another question?
Probably also fixing
my seconds to minutes.
Way back there.
STUDENT: I don't understand,
why did you have to do all that.
Isn't the speed 2
cubic feet per minute?
PROFESSOR: The speed
at which you're
filling it is 2 cubic feet,
but the water level is rising
at a different rate, depending
on whether you're low
down or high up.
It depends on how wide
the pond, the surface, is.
So in fact it's not.
In fact, the answer wasn't
2 cubic-- it wasn't.
There's a rate there.
That is, that's how much
volume is being added.
But then there's another number
that we're keeping track of,
which is the height.
Or, if you like, the
depth of the water.
OK.
So this is the whole
point about related rates.
Is you have one
variable, which is V,
which is volume of something.
You have another
variable, which is
h, which is the height of
the cone of water there.
And you're keeping track of one
variable in terms of the other.
And the relationship will
always be a chain rule
type of relationship.
So, therefore, you'll
be able to-- if you
know one you'll be able
to figure out the other.
Provided you get all
of the related rates.
These are what are
called related rates.
This is a rate of something with
respect to something, etc. etc.
So it's really all
about the chain rule.
And just fitting it
to word problems.
So there's a couple of examples.
And I'll let you
work out some more.
So now, the next thing
that I want to do
is to give you one
more max-min problem.
Which has to do with
this device, which
I brought with me.
So this is a ring.
Happens to be a
napkin ring, and this
is some parachute string, which
I use when I go backpacking.
And the question is
if you have a-- you
think of this is a
weight, it's flexible.
It's allowed to move along here.
And the question is, if I fix
these two ends where my two
hands are, where my
right hand is here
and where my left
hand is over there.
And the question is, where
does this ring settle down.
Now, it's obvious, or
should be maybe obvious,
is that if my two hands
are at equal heights,
it should settle in the middle.
The question that
we're trying to resolve
is what if one hand is a
little higher than the other.
What happens, or
if the other way.
Where does it settle down?
So in order to depict
this problem properly,
I need two volunteers
to help me out.
Can I have some help?
OK.
So I need one of you to hold
the right side, and one of you
to hold the left side.
OK.
And just hold it
against the blackboard.
We're going to trace.
So stick it about here,
in the middle somewhere.
And now we want to make
sure that this one is
a little higher, all right?
So we'll have to-- yeah,
let's get a little higher up.
That's probably good enough.
So the experiment has been done.
We now see where this thing is.
But, so now hold on tight.
This thing stretches.
So we want to get it
stretched so that we
can see what it is properly.
So this thing isn't heavy
enough for this demonstration.
I should've had a ten-ton
brick attached there.
But if I did that,
than I would tax my,
right, I would tax your
abilities to-- right,
so we're going to try to trace
out what the possibilities are
here.
So this is, roughly
speaking, where this thing--
and so now where does it settle.
Well, it settles about here.
So we're going to put
that as X marks the spot.
OK, thank you very much.
Got to remember where
those dots-- OK, all right.
Sorry, I forgot
to mark the spots.
OK, so here's the situation.
We have a problem.
And we've hung a string.
And it went down like this
and then it went like that.
And we discovered
where it settled.
Physically.
So we want to explain this
mathematically, and see what's
going on with this problem.
So this is a real-life problem.
It honestly is the
problem you have to solve
if you want to build a bridge.
Like, a suspension bridge.
This, among many problems.
It's a very serious
and important problem.
And this is the simplest
one of this type.
So we've got our shape here.
This should be a straight
line, maybe not quite as angled
as that.
The first, we've already
drawn the diagram
and we've more or
less visualized
what's going on here.
But the first step after the
diagram is to give letters.
Is to label things
appropriately.
And I do not expect you to be
able to do this, at this stage.
Because it requires
a lot of experience.
But I'm going to do it for you.
We're going to just do that.
So the simplest
thing to do is to use
the coordinates of the plane.
And if you do that, it's also
easiest to use the origin.
My favorite number is 0 and
it should be yours, too.
So we're going to make
this point be (0, 0).
Now, there's another fixed
point in this problem.
And it's this point over here.
And we don't know what
its coordinates are.
So we're just going to
give them letters, a and b.
But those letters
are going to be
fixed numbers in this problem.
And we want to solve it for
all possible a's and b's.
Now, the interesting
thing, remember,
is what happens when b Is not 0.
If b = 0, we already have
a clue that the point
should be the center point.
It should be exactly
that X, the middle point,
which I'm going to label in a
second, is halfway in between.
So now the variable point that
I'm going to use is down here.
I'm going to call
this point (x, y).
So here's my setup.
I've now given labels to all the
things on the diagram so far.
Most of the things
on the diagram.
So now, what else
do I have to do?
Well, I have to explain to you
that this is a minimization
problem.
What happens,
actually, physically
is that the weight settles
to the lowest point.
That's the thing that has
the lowest potential energy.
So we're minimizing a function.
And it's this curve here.
The constraint is that we're
restricted to this curve.
So this is a constraint curve.
And we want the lowest
point of this curve.
So now, we need a little
bit more language in order
to describe what it
is that we've got.
And the constraint curve, we
got it in a particular way.
Namely, we strung some
string from here to there.
And what happens
at all these points
is that the total length
of the string is the same.
So one way of expressing
the constraint
is that the length of
the string is constant.
And so in order to figure
out what the constraint is,
what this curve is, I have to
describe that analytically.
And I'm going to do that by
drawing in some helping lines.
Namely, some right triangles to
figure out what this length is.
And what the other length is.
So this length is pretty easy
if I draw a right triangle here.
Because we go over
x and we go down y.
So this length is the
square root of x^2 + y^2.
That's the Pythagorean theorem.
Similarly, over here, I'm
going to get another length.
Which is a little bit of a mess.
It's the vertical.
So I'm just going to label one
half of it, so that you see.
So this horizontal
distance is x.
And this horizontal
distance from this top
point with this right
angle, over there.
It starts at x and ends at a.
The right-most point is
a in the x-coordinate.
So the whole distance is a - x.
So that's this leg of
this right triangle.
And, similarly, the vertical
distance will be b - y.
And so, the formula here,
which is a little complicated
for this length, is the square
root of (a-x)^2 + (b-y)^2.
So here are the
two formulas that
are going to allow me to
set up my problem now.
So, my goal is to set it
up the way I did here, just
with formulas.
And not with diagrams
and not with names.
So here's what I'd like to do.
I claim that what's constrained,
if I'm along that curve,
is that the total
length is constant.
So that's this statement here.
The square root of x^2 + y^2
plus this other square root.
These are the two
lengths of string.
Is equal to some number,
L, which is constant.
And this, as I said, is what
I'm calling my constraint.
Yeah.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So the question
is, shouldn't it be b+y.
No, and the reason is that
y is a negative number.
It's below 0.
So it's actually the sum,
-y is a positive number.
All right, so
here's the formula.
And then, we want to find
the minimum of something.
So what is it that we're
finding the minimum of?
This is actually the
hardest part of the problem,
conceptually.
I tried to prepare it, but it's
very hard to figure this out.
We're finding the least what?
It's y.
We got a name for that.
So we want to find the lowest y.
Now, the reason why it
seems a little weird
is you might think of y
as just being a variable.
But really, y is a function.
It's really y = y(x)
is defined implicitly
by the constraint equation.
That's what that curve is.
And notice the bottom
point is exactly
the place where the tangent
line will be horizontal.
Which is just what we want.
So from the diagram, the
bottom point is where y' = 0.
So this is the critical point.
Yeah?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
So I'm deriving for
you-- so the question
is, could I have just tried
to find y' = 0 to begin with.
The answer is yes, absolutely.
And in fact I'm leading
in that direction.
I'm just showing
you, so I'm trying
to make the following,
very subtle, point.
Which is in
maximum-minimum problems,
we always have to keep
track of two things.
Often the interesting point
is the critical point.
And that indeed turns
out to be the case here.
But we always have
to check the ends.
And so there are several
ways of checking the ends.
One is, we did this
physical problem.
We can see that
it's coming up here.
Therefore the bottom must
be at this critical point.
So that's OK, so that's
one way of checking it.
Another way of checking it is
the reasoning that I just gave.
But it's really
the same reasoning.
I'm pointing to
this thing and I'm
showing you that the bottom
is somewhere in the middle.
So, therefore, it is a place
of horizontal tangency.
That's the reasoning
that I'm using.
So, again, this
is to avoid having
to evaluate a limit
of an end or to use
the second derivative
test, which
is a total catastrophe
in this case.
OK, now.
There's one other
thing that you might
know about this if you've seen
this geometric construction
before.
With a string and chalk.
Which is that this
curve is an eclipse.
It turns out, this is
a piece of an eclipse.
It's a huge ellipse.
These two points turn out
to be the so-called foci
of the ellipse.
However, that geometric fact
is totally useless for solving
this problem.
Completely useless.
If you actually write out
the formulas for the ellipse,
you'll discover that you
have a much harder problem
on your hands.
And it will take you
twice or ten times
as long, so, it's true
that it's an ellipse,
but it doesn't help.
OK, so what we're going to
do instead is much simpler.
We're going to leave
this expression alone
and we're just going to
differentiate implicitly.
So again, we use
implicit differentiation
on the constraint equation.
So that's the equation which
is directly above me there,
at the top.
And I have to differentiate
it with respect to x.
So that's a little
ugly, but we've
done this a few times before.
When you differentiate
a square root,
the square root goes
into the denominator.
And there's a factor of 1/2,
so there's a 2x which cancels.
So I claim it's this.
Now, because y depends on
x, there's also a y y' here.
So technically speaking,
it's twice this with a half.
2/2 times that.
So that's the differentiation
of the first piece of this guy.
Now I'm going to
do this second one,
and it's also the chain rule.
But you're just going to
have to let me do it for you.
Because it's just a little
bit too long for you
to pay attention to.
It turns out there's
a minus sign that
comes out, because there's
a - x and a - y there.
And then the numerator,
the denominator
is the same massive square root.
So it's (a - (a-x)^2, (b-y)^2.
And the numerator
is a - x, which is
what replaces the x over here.
And then another term,
which is (b-y)y'.
I claim that that's analogous
to what I did in the first term.
And you'll just have to
check this on your own.
Because I did it
too fast for you
to be able to check yourself.
Now, that's going to be equal
to what, on the right-hand side?
What's the derivative
of L with respect to x?
It's 0.
It's not changing
in the problem.
Although my parachute
stuff stretches.
We tried to stretch it
to its fullest extent.
So that we kept it fixed,
that was the goal here.
So now, this looks
like a total mess.
But, it's not.
And let me show you why.
It simplifies a great deal.
And let me show you exactly how.
So, first of all,
the whole point
is we're looking for
the place where y' = 0.
So that means that these
terms go away. y' = 0.
So they're gone.
And now what we have is
the following equation.
It's x divided by square root of
x^2 + y^2 is equal to, if I put
it on the other side the minus
sign is changed to a plus sign,
a - x divided by this
other massive object,
(a-x)^2 + (b-y)^2.
So this is what
it simplifies to.
Now again, that also might
look complicated to you.
But I claim that
this is something,
this is a kind of
equilibrium equation
that can be interpreted
geometrically,
in a way that is very
meaningful and important.
So first of all, let me
observe for you that this x is
something on our picture.
And the square root of x^2 +
y^2 is something on our picture.
Namely, if I go over to
the picture, here was x
and this was a right triangle.
And this hypotenuse was
square root of x^2 + y^2.
So, if I call this angle alpha,
then this is the sine of alpha.
Right?
It's a right triangle,
that's the opposite leg.
So this guy is
the sine of alpha.
Similarly, the other side
has an interpretation
for the other right triangle.
If this angle is beta, then
the opposite side is a-x,
and the hypotenuse is what was
in the denominator over there.
So this side is sine of beta.
And so what this
condition is telling us
is that alpha = beta.
Which is the hidden
symmetry in the problem.
I don't know if you
can actually see it
when I show you this thing.
But, no matter how I tilt
it, actually the two angles
from the horizontal
are the same.
In the middle it's
kind of obvious
that that should be the case.
But on the sides
it's not obvious
that that's what's happening.
Now, this has even-- so that's
a symmetry, if you like,
of the situation.
These two angles are equal.
But there's something
more to be said.
If you do a force diagram for
this, what you'll discover
is that the tension on
the two lines is the same.
Which means that when
you build something
which is hanging like this, it
will involve the least stress.
If you hang
something very heavy,
and one side carries twice
as much load as the other,
then you have twice as
much chance of its falling
and breaking.
If they each hold
the same strength,
then you've distributed the load
in a much more balanced way.
So this is a kind of
a balance condition,
and it's very typical of
minimization problems.
And fortunately, there
are nice solutions
which distribute the
weight reasonably well.
That's certainly the principle
of suspension bridges.
So yeah, one more question.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK, so
the question where
it hangs, that is, what
the formula for x is
and what the formula for y is.
And other things, like the
equation for the ellipse
and lots of other
stuff like that.
Those are things that I
will answer for you in a set
of notes which I will hand out.
And they're just a mess.
You see they're, just
as in that other problem
that we did last time, there's
some illuminating things you
can say about the
problem and then
there's some messy formulas.
You know, you want to try to
pick out the simple things
that you can say.
In fact, that's a
property of math,
you want to focus on the
more comprehensible things.
On the other hand,
it can be done.
It just takes a little
bit of computation.
So I didn't answer the question
of what the lowest y was.
But I'll do that for you.
Maybe I'll just mention one
more thing about this problem.
This is a very amusing problem
from a completely different
point of view.
If you sort of roll
the ellipse around,
you get the same phenomenon
from each place here.
So it doesn't matter
where a and 0 are.
You'll get the same phenomenon.
That is, the tangent line.
So, this angle and that
angle will be equal.
So you can also read that
as being the angle over here
and the angle over
here are equal.
That is, beta-- that is
the complementary angles
are also equal.
And if you interpret
this as a ray of light,
and this as a mirror,
then this would
be saying that if you start at
one focus, every ray of light
will bounce and go
to the other focus.
So that's a property
that an ellipse has.
More precisely, a property
that this kind of curve has.
And in fact, a few
years ago there
was this great piece
of art at something
called the DeCordova Museum,
which I recommended very highly
to you go sometime to visit
in your four years here.
There was a collection
of miniature golf holes.
So they had a bunch of
mini golf pieces of art.
And every one was completely
different from the other.
And one of them was
called hole in one.
And the tee was at one
focus of the ellipse.
And the hole was at the
other focus of the ellipse.
So, no matter how you
hit the golf ball,
it always goes into the hole.
No matter where it bounces,
it just, one bounce
and it's in the hole.
So that's actually a
consequence of the computation
that we just did.
Time to go on.
We're going to now talk
about something else.
So our next topic
is Newton's method.
Which is one of the greatest
applications of calculus.
And I'm going to
describe it here for you.
And we'll illustrate
it on an example,
which is solving the
equation x^2 = 5.
We're going to find
the square root of 5.
Now, you can actually solve
any equation this way.
Any equation that
you understand,
you can solve this
way, essentially.
So even though I'm doing it
for the square root of 5, which
is something that you can
figure out on your calculator,
in fact this is
really at the heart
of many of the ways in
which calculators work.
So, the first thing is to make
this problem a little bit more
abstract.
We're going to set
f(x) = x^2 - 5.
And then we're going
to solve f(x) = 0.
So this is the sort of standard
form for solving such a--
So you take some either
complicated or simple function
of x, linear
functions are boring,
quadratic functions are
already interesting.
And cubic functions, as
I've said a few times,
you don't even have
formulas for solving.
So this would be the
only method you have
for solving them numerically.
So here's how it works.
So the idea, I'll
plot this function.
Here's the function, it's
a parabola, y = x^2 - 5.
It dips below 0, sorry, it
should be centered, but anyway.
And now the idea here is
to start with a guess.
And square root of 5 is pretty
close to the square root of 4,
which is 2.
So my first guess is
going to be 2, here.
So start with initial guess.
So that's our first guess.
And now, what we're
going to do is
we're going to pretend that
the function is linear.
That's all we're going to do.
And then if the
function were linear,
we're going to try to
find where the 0 is.
So if the function is
linear, what we'll use
is we'll plot the point
where 2 is on, that is,
the point (2, f(2)),
and then we're
going to draw the
tangent line here.
And this is going
to be our new guess.
x equals x, which I'll call x_1.
So the idea here is that this
point may be somewhat far
from where it crosses, but this
point will be a little closer.
And now we're going to do
this over and over again.
And see how fast it gets to
the place we're aiming for.
So we have to work out
what the formulas are.
And that's the strategy.
So now, the first step
here is, we have our guess,
we have our tangent line.
Which has the formula
y - y_0 = m(x - x_0).
So that's the general
form for a tangent line.
And now, I have to
tell you what x_1 is.
In terms of this tangent
line. x_1 is the x-intercept.
The tangent line, if you look
over here at the diagram,
the tangent line
is the orange line.
Where that crosses the axis,
that's where I want to put x_1.
So that's the x-intercept.
Now, how do you find
the x-intercept?
You find it by setting y = 0.
That horizontal line is y = 0.
So I set y = 0, and I get
0 - y_0 = m (x_1 - x_0).
So I changed two things
in this equation.
I plugged in 0 here, for y.
And I said that the
place where that happens
is going to be where x is x_1.
So now let's solve.
And what we get here is
-.y divided by-- sorry,
-y_0 / m = x_1 - x_0.
And now I can get
a formula for x_1.
So x_1 = x_0 - y_0 / m.
I now need to tell you
what this formula means,
in terms of the function f.
So first of all, x_0 is
x_0, whatever x_0 is.
And y_0, I claim, is f(x_0).
And m is the slope
at that same place.
So it's f'(x_0).
And this is the whole story.
This is the formula which
will enable us to calculate
basically any root.
I'm going to repeat
this formula,
so I'm going to
tell you again what
Newton's method is,
and put a little more
colorful box around it.
So Newton's method involves
the following formula.
In order to get
the (n+1)st point,
that's our better
and better guess,
I'm going to take the nth one
and then I'm going to plug
in this formula.
So f(x_n) / f'(x_n).
So this is the basic
formula, and if you like,
this is the idea of just
repeating what I had before.
Now, we've gone from
geometry, from just pictures,
to an honest to
goodness formula which
is completely
implementable and very easy
to implement in any case.
So let's see how it works
in the case that we've got.
Which is x_0 = 2.
f(x) = x^2 - 5.
Let's see how to
implement this formula.
So first of all, I have to
calculate for you, f'(x).
That's 2x.
And so, x_1 is equal to
x_0 minus, so f', sorry,
f(x) would be x_0^2 - 5.
That's what's in the numerator.
And in the denominator
I have the derivative,
so that's 2 x_0.
And so all told, well, let's
work it out in two steps here.
This is -1/2 x_0
for the first term,
and then plus (5/2) /
x_0 for the second term.
And these two terms combine, so
we have here 1/2 x_0 plus 5/2
with an x_0 in the denominator.
So here's the formula
for x_1. in this case.
Now I'd like to show
you how well this works.
So first of all, we have x_1
is 1/2 * 2, if I plug in x1,
plus 5/4, which is 9/4.
And x_2, I have 1/2
* 9/4 + + 5/2 * 4/9.
That's the next one.
And if you work this
out, it's 161/72.
And then x_3 is kind of long.
But I will just write down what
it is, so that you can see.
It's 1/2 * 161/72
plus 5/2 and then
I do the reciprocal of that.
So 72/161.
So let's see how good these are.
I carefully calculated
how far off they are.
Somewhere on my notes.
So I'll just take a look
and see what I said.
Oh yeah, I did do it.
So, what's the square root
of 5 minus-- so here's n,
here's the square root of
5 minus x_n, if you like.
Or the other way around.
The size of this.
You'll have to decide
on your homework
whether it comes out positive
or negative, to the right
or to the left of the answer.
But let's do this.
So when n = 0, the guess was 2.
And we're off by
about 2 * 10^(-1).
And if n = 1, so
that's this 9/4,
that's off by about 10^(-2).
And then n = 2, that's
this number here, right?
And that's off by
about 4 * 10^(-5).
That's already as
good an approximation
to the square root of 5 as
you'll ever need in your life.
If you do 3, this number
here turns out to be accurate
to 10^(-10) or so.
This goes right off to the
edge of my calculator, this one
here.
So already, with
the third iterate.
you're of way past the accuracy
that you need for most things.
Yep, question.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: How come
the x_0 disappears?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE] PROFESSOR:
So, from here to here
[INAUDIBLE]
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Hang on,
folks, we have a question.
Let's just answer it.
So here we have an x_0,
and here we have -1/2,
there's an x_0^2 and
an x which cancel.
And here we have a
minus, and a -5/2 x0.
So I combine the 1 - 1/2,
I got +1/2, that's all.
OK?
All right, thanks.
We'll have to ask other
questions after class.